we're joined now by stephanie
rawlings-blake if her name and her face
sounds familiar it's because she's used
to dealing with tragedy and controversy
she's a former mayor of baltimore she's
now serving as travis scott's
spokesperson stephanie it's good to see
you i'm very sorry it's under these
circumstances this story is
heartbreaking on so many different
levels you know there's a lot of finger
pointing going on much of it directed to
travis scott in particular from some of
the people who were there that night can
you tell us when was he aware that this
concert had turned into such a tragedy
so first thank you for uh having me and
it it is sorry that it's under these
circumstances um yeah there's a lot of
confusion as you saw in the clip
proceeding it was chaotic and
just like the police officers who were
standing
in front of the stage with travis nearly
30 minutes after it was declared a
public safety emergency travis had no
idea what was going on until well later
hours and hours later
how was he notified
he was notified by his team
after the event after he was already
gone from the event as you saw there was
so much chaos so much breakdown uh in
the communication and that's why it was
important for me uh to to work to try to
help him out nine people have lost their
lives nine families are grieving and and
gail i'm a mom my daughter's gone to one
of these big concerts and i can tell you
i spent three sleepless nights every day
watching my phone watching her location
because when you have crowds of 50 000
people anything can happen and while a
lot of people are trying to place the
blame travis is taking responsibility
for moving forward and trying to make
sure this never happens again to
anyone's child
yeah there are reports that he had gone
to dave and busters and was partying i
think it's important to point out that
when he was at dave and busters he
couldn't possibly have known that this
was that this had
devolved into what it had become
no absolutely not he was there trying to
regroup with his team
they were trying to figure out what was
going on it was hours and hours after
the concert when they actually found out
the tragedy how the tragedy unfolded and
he has not stopped grieving for these
families he knows that he is who he is
because of his fans his love for his
fans is so deep i was struck when i was
speaking to him how deeply he was
hurting because of what happened to
the people he loves and in the city that
he loves
yeah i heard you say that he's taken
responsibility what do you mean by that
and he wants to make sure this doesn't
happen again what do you mean
when i say responsibility someone has to
say
where are the breakdowns where was the
communication breakdown where was the
public safety breakdown i mean this
notion that travis had the ability to
stop the concert is ludicrous they have
a 59
page operations plan and it clearly says
the only two people that are
have the authority to stop the concert
where the executive producer and the
concert producer
he was not responsible for this but he
wants to be responsible for the solution
and i'm here to make sure that we can
connect the dots and to make sure that
this tragedy that there's a lesson out
of this tragedy and something like this
doesn't happen again
you know you pointed out there is video
of police officers in front of the stage
they actually seem to be enjoying the
concert they were seem to be singing
along and videotaping
and they're right in front of travis at
the time so they didn't appear to be
aware of it certainly travis didn't
appear to be aware of it did travis
scott and your and his team have any
conversations with officials before
about safety at this event
yes his team is always concerned about
safety um you know he does not hide from
the fact that in the past he has made
mistakes but one thing he said to me and
he looked me in his uh in my eyes and
said that he's learned from that and
that's why he takes safety so
seriously he stopped when he saw that
some he saw that something was a myth he
couldn't tell what it was but he's so
concerned about his fans he stopped you
in the video show he stopped multiple
times to try to get a sense of what was
going on and just like those police
officers that were standing in front of
the stage he could not tell what was
going on
has he reached out to any of the
families stephanie
oh absolutely
first i want to say that we're
respectful he's very respectful of their
their need for privacy and space as they
grieve but he's reached out to all of
the families
i've reached out to
the latest
unfortunate victim to let them know that
in their time
um he's there he's here to help if they
want hit
all right stephanie rawlings-blake thank
you for taking the time to speak with us
this morning thank you my pleasure